you mentioned the whole like search
term things with women it's like you
know
uh pirates like all these
pirates werewolves vampires these
creatures these monsters that are
supposed to be like dangerous and things
yeah
the other big search term that women
look for is
gangbang porn oh yeah and what does that
imply well it tends to imply
like rape fantasy and this sort of stuff
and uh
i don't know if you've ever read the
book my secret garden by nancy friday
no tell me about it so this is a book
she uh i think she was like a new york
times journalist at the time
she basically put an advert out saying
in in the new york times saying
asking women to write in anonymously
their deepest darkest sexual fantasies
and then she took all these fantasies
and compiled them into a book and that
book is my secret garden
and about 90 of it is rape fantasies
you know what's interesting about that
um i can't remember which evo
evo psych book it was in but that's
mostly what i've been reading the last
couple years or listening to anyway
because i use audible
but um there was one that i came across
where they were talking about the
instances of
pregnancies and marriages versus rape
and it's actually a lot harder to get
pregnant than what people think and of
course it's
you know part of that is because people
are waiting till later on in life to go
and
have families and you know stuff like
that but the
instances of uh pregnancies are twice as
high
during rape versus people that are
actually trying to conceive
using like apps with like you know
cycling and all that sort of stuff
wow that is that is a mind-blowing
now there's some arguments that that say
that
it's it's usually more attractive
younger women that that get raped
meaning that they're more fertile
right like they're probably earlier on
in their um you know years of dropping x
sort of thing so there might be some
some component of that to it but
i found it interesting i mean because
like technically you don't want it to
happen
um you know it's a traumatic experience
yet the pregnancy rate is twice as high
as people actually trying to conceive
children
well that kind of leads into the whole
uh war brides
phenomenal yeah women are very like they
love
accommodating their conquerors yeah
throughout history they've always done
it i mean they've had to do because if
they didn't do it then they would die
exactly right so it's this thing that is
inherently programmed
into like the female brain and female
biology is like
yeah what's that what's that term that
roller uses for
women that like pine after guys that are
in jail like like they're convicted
murderers are on death row
like there's this entire like groupie
genre of like women that will
want to go like they letter them they
send the money if they have conjugal
visits and they're allowed to have
like for some reason guys like this just
get late it's
it's something philly i don't know that
much uh
crazy ass felia right there
oh hyper hybristophilia that's it that's
the one yeah hybristophere there yeah
the idea
yeah being because it only happens to
women it doesn't happen to dudes
like only women have hybristophilia this
is the the
term up right now from wikipedia uh is a
paraphilia in which sexual arousal
facilitation attainment of orgasm
are responsive to and contingent upon
being with a partner
known to have committed an outrage
cheating lying
known infidelities or crime such as rape
or murder
that's hybristophelia and uh dudes do
not have this
no but hey bro men and women are the
same that's what they keep telling us
that's exactly 100 exactly the same
this whole the whole war brides thing is
sort of
i mean you look at you look you go back
through history you go back through time
it's like women have the capacity to
fall in love with and and pair bond
to a man who has murdered her husband
probably probably raped her and probably
also killed her children with that
previous husband
yeah i suppose it's it's it's got a lot
to do with the whole capacity for
violence and the demonstration of
violence like roller said you know it's
dhv like demonstrating higher value
you know it's also like you know it's
also part of the reason why like a woman
would rather date a guy that lives with
his wife
than date a guy that lives with his
parents in their parents basement
right like you know it's a whole
pre-selection thing too right oh
dude and i've on this channel for those
of you who might be
might be new i interview porn stars here
in the studio with me
and i've had a couple of different
examples because they're pretty
porn stars are pretty honest being if
i'm being fair the girls don't really
have much to hide
because they're already out on the
internet like everyone's seen their ass
you know they've seen them suck on a
deck it's not a big deal for them to
sort of be honest about
their sexual history so i had this one
girl on the show who was
when she was actually underage
so when she was she admitted to this
when she was 17 or i think it was 16 she
was working in a starbucks or something
and this wealthy kind of businessman
dude like a dorian gray type came into
the shop
floated got her number he was in his 40s
50s
she was like 16 17. she ended up seeing
this guy
for a good two or three i think was a
good couple of years
married married married with kids yeah
uh and i said in
um you know the whole idea that the
whole
idea of him being married with kids
didn't phase her whatsoever
if anything was it made her but she
didn't know that initially but if
anything it made it made it more
attractive to him
and i remember saying to her i'm like
you know and she's only like 18 now
18 19 now uh and i said to it you
realize that you could have completely
ruined that man's life with one phone
call right mm-hmm
and she's like yeah yeah i knew it yeah
she knew it she was perfectly aware of
the fact that she could just destroy his
life
uh because she was you know you actually
surprised how many guys i've i've talked
to over the last couple years that i've
been married for like 20 years i got
four kids been with the same woman the
whole time but they have a notch count
of like 200 during the marriage
yeah you know just because they're out
there doing whatever they want and their
wives just look the other way
see women are very interesting right
like they actually talk
so much about how they hate cheaters and
all sorts of stuff but they'll marry
them they'll have kids with them and
they'll look the other way while they
continue to
you know slam other women as long as
they continue to get
the financial resources the attention
and the and the protection women are
fine to share guys right you know
um i don't know where it came from but i
first saw it in one of rollo's books but
it's like you know women would rather
share a high value alpha than be
straddled with a faithful loser
dude and it's so true right it's so
[ __ ] true
people i mean i've done an episode on
this
before and i talked to our mutual friend
paul benjamin about this
the idea of like male and female
jealousy being completely different but
what do you hear okay like whenever
whenever a guy
uh gets like jealous that is
this missus is probably cheating on him
right what's the mainstream now
narrative response it's oh
you're insecure in your masculinity
well here's the thing like insecurity is
is the is a is the female cause of
jealousy
right the idea that oh he's gonna okay
he's got me pregnant
but he's in love with somebody else so
he's gonna provide all his resources and
protection to her
right i'm gonna it's like if we're
talking evolutionary back in caveman
days
i'm probably gonna die if i'm pregnant
he's not there to protect me i'm
probably gonna die
so that insecurity that in
in terms of your inability to retain a
high value man
that's where female jealousy comes from
but with male jealousy
it's a case of oh like i've spent my
resources on this woman
and the kid isn't even mine she's cucked
right eternity yeah you want to make
sure the kid's yours because women
always have 100
assurance of paternity because they're
carrying the child they they know it's
theirs it's just
who's the father now exactly and it's
and
and this talks a bit about this kind of
relates to solipsism
right the idea that women sort of always
perceive the world through
their ob like their subjective lens
they're utterly incapable of seeing
it through the masculine lens exactly
and uh
so whenever whenever the idea of
jealousy comes up
they immediately default their
perception which is
insecurity but with dudes like dudes can
get jealous without being insecure it's
not it's not related to insecurity with
men it's related to like
loss of investment yeah you can go out
and
you know have a threesome with a couple
of you know garden tools and come home
to your wife and your kids and you know
still lying
bad next to your wife and kiss her good
night and love her to bets right
you still love her and still and still
be committed to her
that's why guys have that capacity but
women don't but women think that they do
because they've been told that they can
be guys so they go out there trying to
cheat on their husbands and they have
this like internal conflict in their own
dna it's it's
it's so bizarre dude that is exactly and
and i'm glad you mentioned that because
so i've i've had this experience on set
right and i
and i mentioned this in my last
interview
with that when i had a porn star in here
it was like i'll i'll notice this
when i'm on set with a girl if i'm
shooting with her and she
if i know that she has a boyfriend a
husband a partner
or is just sort of dating a guy who is
high value who i can who she perceives
as being
her best option i can tell
straight away because she has she's not
she's not there she's not present with
the sex
it's a chore it's a job for her because
she in her head she has this lingering
guilt
of like man i don't really want i'd
rather have that dick
my guy's dick in me than that random
sterling pornstar studies
and that and that's a good example of uh
transactional sex versus validational
sex like the highest value guy that
she's in the relationship with
that she's you know still still like top
of the list for her
that's the validational component the
transactional component is i'm going to
[ __ ] sterling and take my
i don't know whatever they get paid
their thousand dollars and go home
but it's that but that's uh the idea you
just raised if
women are taught that they can sleep
around like dudes and still be in love
with
you know their their man at home well if
you pay them a thousand bucks as a porn
star then they'll do it right but
you're not going to get where this you
know like the wettest fidget ever right
no no this is why we have lube on set
uh and i recommend a pure silicone lube
for anyone listening
so it's the best lube in the business i
know i've tried them all
uh but
the cause this comes up when i'm talking
to porn stars about like relationships
and things and
and why uh they
what tends to happen is a porn star will
get into a relationship with it with a
civilian dude
and then the guy is like oh man this is
great this is they're sort of
seduced by the allure of [ __ ] upon so
they're seduced by the potential of
amazing sex like this is gonna be the
best sex i've ever had and i can brag to
my friends about
banging them uh et cetera right let me
ask you this question so
if you have a porn star that you're
banging that's in a relationship with a
dude i mean i'm assuming that you know
who these guys are right you you've
either met them or you see their links
on
on social like are we talking about like
guys that are
deemed to be higher value but they're
obviously cucked like like there's
something wrong with them
well it's not all of them date other
porn stars
so some of them yeah some of them are in
relationships with
male talent and they tend to be high
value male talent they tend to be like
some of the best dudes in the industry
okay we'll let these chicks down like
top top tier dudes tend to date top tier
girls
yeah but i mean like we always also see
this like trend like um
who's that who's that one recently uh
mia khalifa she got with that
uh high value chef right um
i don't know what he does for a living
but i think he's a chef or something
like that you know but she abandoned her
porn career
to go and go and enter his frame but at
the end of the day i mean
the guy's basically a [ __ ] like even if
she's not getting banged by other guys
right now
she spent her you know her time
and that's how she's known her best
years she's been she's been her best
years
getting railed out for very little money
uh
and and what you'll see is
girls will belittle each other for that
for if if a girl if a girl falls for a
dude a high value dude and she's like
i would rather be with this guy than
than do porn
and drops out of the industry all the
other porn girls
will shame her for it although they'll
specifically shame the dude they'll be
like
you're making you're being domineering
you're making her
make bad life choices you're making her
oh you're controlling
yeah you're controlling like they're
they're trying to justify their own
shitty life choices
by demeaning someone who's actually
making a better life choice like
if we're being honest like if she's
found a guy who wants like
you know tip attack if she's found a guy
who's into her
who's got got the frame and she's like
all right i'm going to leave all this
[ __ ] behind because i want to be with
you
well that's far better than her sticking
around in porn and being with him at the
same time
because what happens is these dudes get
into relationships with these chicks and
then six months later
they they the honeymoon phase wears off
and the guy's like hmm i'm actually not
comfortable with my my chick sucking
dick all the time
for a living and then they bring the
ultimatum comes up
and they tell the girls oh look it's
either me or the pawn right
right rather than doing it at the very
beginning of the relationship
which if they if they're going to date a
pawn so they should probably do it there
i would probably advise against dating
yeah they can
that's the you know that's the innate
hard-wiring with men right like they
want
like they want to know that she
is only banging you because of the
assurance of paternity that's why guys
get jealous so he's
so he's so he's trying to cut off that
that path
and of course i bet a lot of these guys
that are dating porn stars that
aren't porn stars themselves and they
pull them out of porn
they're probably very success you know
very successful they make bank
and at the same time they're like look i
think you've had enough of the carousel
i don't want
you know guys running a train on you
every week um
you know let's call us a day and i'll
take care of you financially and then
they go and
you know do some born-again christian
[ __ ] have a baby
like jenna j jameson right yeah offer
their
opinions all the time on social media
like anybody should care but yet they
still
get millions of followers on it
it was recently uh if anyone is familiar
with uh
logan paul who's a youtuber he has
a guy who's sort of in his crew i think
his friend's name's mike or whatever and
his friend mike is on his youtube
channel all the time
he has been dating lana rhodes recently
who was like
this year who's like the most she's the
top search
porn star on the planet right now and
he's been dating her but she hasn't
she hasn't shot porn for like [ __ ]
forever but these girls still make money
off their only fans and stuff you know
so it's sort of
the guys what happens is the guys the
girls just don't marry them
the girls end up pimping the dudes
because what they'll do the dudes end up
being
if they're a civilian guy they end up
being the stunt [ __ ] in her her videos
right so it's all point of view content
then the dude sometimes they'll tend to
shack up this is what i see with guys
who are
civilians that marry pawn chicks the
dudes tend to do all the video editing
all the photography for them
all the filming for them uh they manage
their like
their website they manage their
inventory when they're selling panties
and things
so they're just ripping out dirty
panties to some random dude on
the internet dude my friends i was
having this conversation with my friend
sarah j
when i was in miami with her she has she
doesn't have a
have a partner but she has a she's like
she's like a team of like 12 people
helping her out man she's a [ __ ]
empire
but she has one personal assistant who
is dedicated to selling her panties
that's her entire job she can't she sell
so she buys like a pack of 10 panties
uh they cost her maybe two dollars a pop
or something
and she'll wear them for like a day and
then sell them for 50 bucks
i bet there's panties that go out she
doesn't even wear he probably puts them
on
he'll probably put some on blows a fart
you know you know sweats in them for a
little bit
then ships them off in the mail
oh these are used here you could have
these buddy
oh god sweaty bowls we're laughing
because it's true
you